Cleveland Browns got a big game against
the Ravens coming up this weekend in
Baltimore
and it felt like a good time to bring in
Mary Kay Cabot who covers the Cleveland
Browns for Cleveland calm the Cleveland
Plain Dealer how is morale there Mary
Kay you know it's okay I actually think
that Rex Ryan did the Browns a huge
favor and Baker Mayfield a big favor by
saying he was overrated as hell you know
Baker needs that he needs that fire lit
under him to get really motivated and to
get his game face on
and I actually think he's really going
to come out fighting on Sunday but I
also think that there is some truth some
validity to what Rex was saying I just
made the headlines that when he says
that he's overrated as hell then
everybody was like a gasp like and then
I go okay now explain yourself and then
he said some things that I thought were
accurate and now do you think the Browns
look at that or a baker looks at that
and says you know what maybe there is
some truth in what he was pointing out
here you know there is some truth to
some of the things that are happening to
Baker on the field this year I think
defensive coordinators and he must face
some really good ones have caught up to
him a little bit and they're doing
things like confusing him at the line of
scrimmage and smashing him to the right
but you know actually the Ravens are
giving up a lot of yards this year and I
think there will be opportunities for
him to hit the big plays which he really
needs to do that he needs to get the
ball in the hands of Odell of Jarvis and
he needs to get his confidence back a
little bit and I actually think this is
a week that he might be able to do that
why is Freddie kitchen so reluctant to
give up the play calling I think that he
feels that that's not really the issue I
think he looks out there and sees an
offense that's coming together new
personnel new coaches tweaked schemes
blending schemes and I think he just
feels like they're a play or two away I
think he looks at that goal line stand
and says hey if Baker hits Jarvis on
that underneath route instead of trying
to hit demetrius harris up top in the
back of the end zone they win the game
no one's complaining should we reset our
expectations for this team you know I'll
let you know after so
firstly if they went on Sunday there -
it - they're tied for first in the AFC
North and they're actually ahead because
they will have won beating the Ravens
and be ahead of them in the standings
and so when you look at the second half
of the season not only are they getting
Kareem hunt back they're getting an
Tonio Callaway back they might get David
Joker back but it's a very easy second
half of the season what yeah but that
first half of the season I mean they
could easily be 2 and 6 after 8 games
yeah it's brutal
it's absolutely brutal coming up here
and that is why this Sunday is so
vitally important they have four of
their next five are on the road
their only home game is against the
Seattle Seahawks two of those Road games
are against the Ravens and the Patriots
another one against the 49ers so you're
right they have to stay afloat in these
next four or five games the defense has
been I think underrated how would you
assess the performance so far I agree
with you 100% they played really really
well if you look what they did against
the Rams I mean this is the high flank
second in scoring last year and this was
a Cleveland Browns team that was down a
starting linebacker and almost four
defensive backs and they went out there
and they almost beat the Rams and they
got twenty takeaways so yes I do think
the defense is underrated and I don't
think the Ravens have seen a defense
like this this year I also pointed this
out with Freddie kitchens with Odell
Beckham with Baker Mayfield this is a
team that is so caught up in what people
are saying about them and I know you
said hey Baker maybe he needed this with
what Rex Ryan said but you know my
advice to Freddie kitchens is just stop
acknowledging any of this stuff just say
you know what we're moving on you know
it subscribe to the Bill Belichick
playbook here when it comes to dealing
with the media but to deal to listen to
everything here and and this is how you
start to have cracks in the armor with
the team would just just play it's a you
lost
and then you'll regroup but it feels
like they just continue to carry this
baggage
with them do you sense this when you go
to those press conferences that every
little thing seems to bother them yeah
they talk a lot about blocking out the
noise but they don't right and you talk
a very good game in that way
Baker's never blocked out the night the
noise to his advantage so work that's
never going to change with him but I
agree with you in general they could do
a better job of just letting this stuff
roll off their backs but this is all
some team that has talked big themselves
heading into this season and that hasn't
really helped them with some of the
teams the Titans for instance remember
Delanie Walker heading into that opener
and saying you know we're sick of
Cleveland s include with that
well the Ravens are saying some of the
same things heading into this game and I
can assure you that John Harbaugh will
use that as a rallying cry Mary Kay
thank you as always we appreciate your
time sounds good thank you
Mary Kay Cavett covers the Browns for
Cleveland Plain Dealer
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]